pani giochi e minimum stay fare perché
lo re giorgio ii posto per fare ciò che
è minimo da ribelli non giochi non avere
[Applauso]
capito portaseme è bello bravo tra la
partenza di sto gioco del merda bella
tutti ragazzi della tutti ragazzi solo
che se non avessi guardato in faccia non
sarebbe successo niente mi sbagliavo a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono video
sono fatti j
e oggi siamo sul gioco che mi piace
tantissimo che si chiama e mi di von
stuck lei è proprio un gioco che mi
piace tantissimo proprio bello il gioco
wi fi muovere grazie grazie allora
ragazzuoli siamo suoi minimo stupì sono
passati quattro secondi dall'inizio del
video già preso un jobs che prova in
poche parole ragazzi questo videogame è
un grazie praticamente grazie che
gentile mi aprì anche l'armadio per
cortesia
grazie c'è l'armadio e te le ville al
cazzo è un gioco dove c'è una bambina
che che ti segue e poi c'è un pagliaccio
che ti segue anche quello che in poche
parole un gioco dove nessuno si fa i
cazzi suoi va bè ragazzi
ok ok ok mi abbia via via lia perfetto
in poche parole raga devo resistere
un'ora perché allo scoccare della
prossima ora in teoria si aggiunge un
nuovo nemico come se già non bastassero
la tipa equa la tipa ecco quando c'è la
tipa mi avete detto ma l'avete scritto
nei commenti devo guardarla in faccia
perché se la guardi in faccia se ne va
dai [ __ ]
questa cosa non l'avevo capito e
continuavo a fare il deficente vabbè
comunque la guardo perfetto cosa
facciamo
continua a guardare ecco funziona o
troviamo ragazzi il secondo di mico
perché il pagliaccio mi avete detto che
per superarlo bisogna quando sento il
che fa molto simpatico devo stare fermo
e non muove
non devo guardarlo perché sennò lapio
nel culo vale solo che quella tipa posso
muovermi con il tipo devo stare come
fermo immobile tipo ciro ciro immobile
aiuta sucate grazie comunque ragazzi
alla luce di tutto questo devo resistere
almeno un'oretta senza che mi stuprino
l'anno quando esiste un oretta dovrebbe
apparire un altro nemico io pre cazzo
c'e la mano sul con te lo prendi lo sa
ed efficiente la vedete anche voi a non
sono scemo io se c'è la mano perché non
lo prendi lo che ti servono sono fermo
c'è la porta che si chiuda vai a
controllare la porta che si è chiusa
grazie è molto gentile
ecco bravo zio bravissimo ragazzi
abbiamo sistemato entrambi comunque per
ora non c'è nessuno spero prego possa
accendere tutte le stanze prima che
tornino
sì grazie a dio il vero ragazze me
l'avete veramente spiegato voi come faro
che sono un cazzo che lo capivo che non
è nata la bambina in questo il
principale una donna di cui preciso
istante in cui non doveva esserci la
bambina c'è stata la bambina l'unico
momento in cui ero fermo perché c'era il
pagliaccio grazie grazie mille
dov'è dove dov'è eccoti che culo se non
la vedo e non la guardo in faccia a
rischio di morire perché non la trovo
c'è proprio tipo nascondino non è che
cade a terra e moris e facendo sì che
justin bieber grazie ma mediano like us
everyone che carlo sono sempre è breve
beh ragazzi ho scoperto un'altra cosa
questo gioco la aggiungetela la
descrizione di come finire emili mons to
play
se cantate justin bieber ci avete nel
culo come cia le maniche su grosse 10
volte la sua faccina neanche gianni
morandi il signor a parte gianni e che
che salutiamo che ci sei ciao gianni
ecco ascolta fa fede roba gianni canta
la canzone delle tue che la bambina ha
bisogno di distrarsi da justin bieber
che non è possibile ha voglia di
riscattare quella cazzo di ora o
continuiamo così di tutta la vita sono
passati siano 30 minuti da quando sto
girando come un deficiente proteggendo
il mio anno da questi due individui
loschi ragazzi non ancora visto cosa c'è
sul computer cioè non mi ricordo più
acea già la pizza la pizza perché
quando in atto la pizza su internet
ovviamente in un momento del genere che
fa in ordine alla pizza giusto anzi ci
pensi che la pagina fanno io pago io ti
togli per cortesia che cielo indietro
grazie
madonna ce la possiamo fare a far
scattare un'altra ora per cortesia che
un'ora e mezza che questo sto facendo
così per favore se scatta l'ora ragazze
arrivo più di metà giorno c'è un filo la
metà dei gol solo che so che non ci
arriverò mai
per l'amor di dio la prima volta nella
storia in cui nella tiro è invece vinto
mai successo oddio mica non ci posso
credere assurdo ma qui siamo alla
seconda ora siamo la terza c'è allora la
prima l'ho superata già sulla bambina
adesso superato la seconda ha già è vero
che adesso sono un nemico adesso che ho
passato l'ora c'è un altro nemico nuovo
che in teoria dovrebbe apparire non so
dove non so quando ma finché non compare
sono contento per carità capitana
l'altra [ __ ]
[Musica]
qua invece lodato a vedere che mi sono
cacciati in mano vetta stabili fiera
quel è lui è quello lì in basso a destra
cassano fa vj piacere mi stai sul culo
nel caso non l'avessi capito qual è la
tattica per ragazzi non mi avete detto
la tattica per il terzo come faccio a
batterlo chi era proviamo ad andare di
logica senza andare a vedere come si fa
che gioco di merda e cazzo successo
porca eva però lo strato preso di aver
capito ragazzi per sfuggire al tipo devo
semplicemente andare da una stanza
all'altra prima che vi prenda credo è
che è però c'è anche questo come faccio
a fare tutti insieme non è possibile non
ne posso reggere tre perché mentre sto
fermo che ti guardo che sei bello ma
dovrebbe arrivare un altro a rompermi
maroni quindi e siamo punto a capo
dovrebbe arrivare a eva porca eva non
sto facciamo strega ci posso credere
devo solo stare fermo quando ci sono le
ciao sono fuori j piacere porca eva
porca eva è veramente a carissimo si è
chiusa la porta socchiusa la porta vai a
vedere per cortesia bayern ma vai a
vedere la porta nicchia come visse con
salvate dal tipo che dovevo stare fermo
come se n'è andato corso come un
deficiente io che palle
[Musica]
qualcuno lo diciamo noi
cosa vuole che palle c'è riuscito a
uccidermi il pagliaccio che da quello
vecchio
mi piace quello nuovo ma chi e che cosa
sei
ma perché c'è una bambina la finestra
ogni volta hanno capito ma essa senza
qua è una merda con la stanza l'ho
sempre detto io ma fa boschivo ragazzi
che il suo gioco è a pagamento cioè
della gente se lo compra pure per
giocarci geniale il pupazzo nuovo nel
servizio perché perché io non sto zitto
nella vecchia non potevo cominciare a
parlare per la prima volta a 21 anni
invece che a a2 non facevano fatto in
tempo re gara troppo e roero e
dall'altra parte della stanza che dovevo
fare
non la voglio più guarda caso se ce l'ho
fatta e se invece canti jonas brothers
così proprio ha presa bene presa bene
allora si sa non so se li hai visti
questi sono coltelli i coltelli se li
prendi paino 2 utilità la prima prende e
ci taglia mazzarella seconda utilità
quel pagliaccio con le mani giganti mai
visto prima alla luce di questo perché
alla luce del fatto che ce l'hai pure in
cucina perché non fare di quel gol
grazie avrebbe chiuso la porta sul culo
grazie
madonna che dietro front e incredibile
che ho fatto mi stai mentendo gesù ma
veramente ho fatto un'altra ora non è
vero
reazione verde mi sono mosso mi sono
mosso nessun in cui la virgola miglior
amico lang all amico l'ho ancora la
sapevo che mi ma meno male è scattata la
prima ma meno male
mamma mia che presa ma le ragazze dalla
seconda alla terza ragazzi tanta roba da
guardare gazzoli fatevi stato l'ultimo
tentativo grazie
giusto per capire che cosa qual è il
nuovo nemico giusto per capire che credo
che sia sempre la bambina semplicemente
che prima non c'era porca eva o [ __ ]
tolto le cuffie ho capito che non ci
arrivava la porta quindi ho fatto prima
soglia alle cuffie dai credere che a
soli facciamo che concludere qui il
video anche perché alla fine ci ha avuto
un culo nel togliermi le cuffie in tempo
che va meglio così
avete preso l'infarto tutti però io no
l'unica volta nella vita da soli spero
che capiti e merda ma don questo sono
questo è un horror
spero che ai video vi sia piaciuto nel
prossimo episodio proveremo a vedere che
cosa c'è di nuovo perché non ho visto
qual è il nemico nuovo costruito subito
piaciuto al momento è un mi piace mi
piace doverosissimo per le due ore e
fatti in un episodio solo anche a pagina
di facebook che condivida tratta
descrizione servizi tiscali ci vediamo
al prossimo vinto